no non ce la faccio aspetta si e no
perché stiamo andando da tanto dai ma
che che che intendevo fare questo gioco
va bene allora bene a tutti ragazzi e
benvenuti a questo video sono parigi
oggi siamo succubi
madonna santissima allora ho portato gip
che tra l'altro vinto anche avevo
portato in passato anche pupi che è
stato sempre allo stesso creatore di
circo che si chiamano forti perché è
sempre lo stesso creatore di getting
over i pensate come siamo messi comunque
questo signore ha fatto appunto certo si
sarà fatto anche kubica il più famoso
face venuto non ho fatto niente io non
ho fatto niente è morto
morto bisogna riuscire a fare la corsa
davanti no però bisogna usare sti tasti
che sono cool water della tastiera che
se non fosse perché sto gioco non gli
avrei mai schiacciati al merito
l'obiettivo è arrivare almeno ai 100
metri sostanzialmente gli almeno quelle
delle olimpiadi cosa mi molto complicata
da fare perché nonostante siano passati
ormai
credo dieci anni da quando è uscito tre
no forse di più non del 2008 su giove il
più dvd di più di dieci anni da quando
ci giusto gioco nonostante questo ancora
non si è capito come cacchio fa restare
i primi sono capito come fare stavolta
dunque traguardo record per adesso sono
cinque metri che ho appena fatto mentre
chiacchieravo che non è male
che non è male attenzione pazzesco 6
mentre neanche poi se uno non ci gioca
di fatto è che se uno non ci giocano non
si capisce quanto è improponibile
stappare no devo giocarci porca nella
punta per apprezzare il decadimento
cerebrale e che ti porta ad avere questo
che dovevo giocare sono dal video non si
capisce ma vi assicuro che nel meta che
tentò di imitare cristiano ronaldo
contro la juventus io comunque mi sto
impegnando
per non fare questa cosa fate che c'è
proprio una tecnica che ancora non ho
non ho appurato nonostante siano passati
giorni
come mai questo gioco l'hanno fatto i
babilonesi e nonostante questo non si è
capito un una sega come corre sporco dei
modi tutto sta ragazzi comunque nel
prendere il ritmo perché se prendi il
ritmo non è questo ritmo va bene in
poche parole una persona che veramente
sa giocare a questo gioco che c'è
scritto che si può ti puoi veramente
muovere come un essere umano con skill
il problema è che la skill non ce l'ha
nessuno ce l'hai non è mica c'è qualcuno
già uno skill giusto gioco come non
esiste
cioè se no veramente non avete un
fidanzato barra fidanzata nessuno ce
l'ha perché io non ci voglio credere
però intanto i 12 metri ho fatti di 12
metri ho fatti vado per i quindici mamma
mio fenomeno stiamo scherzando
mica come piove la [ __ ] 20 metri no
ragazzi zitti per impegnarmi la pena
consor dell'area
dai
fare
porca [ __ ] 30 metri non arriva ormai a
30 meno sono fatto ho fatto una provata
finale tanto non so qual è il mio record
ragazzi però comunque ero arrivato pare
mi ricordo che c'era un video in
particolare dove era arrivato parecchio
avanti adesso non vi so dire quale ma
c'è stato un video in cui ho fatto la
giocata del secolo non vi saprei dire
ecco l'importante emulare quel video lì
non so come quanta fatica per arrivare
in 30 di movieye garantirà set sono
arrivate lo rimuove 30 ragazzi comunque
se prendi il via è fatta e non so con
che criterio ma sempre uno prendervi
psicologicamente fatta poi non so bene
ok mica l'ho ripresa lo riela ripresa
avellino la ripresa pesino ero caduto
alla ripresa con una skin incredibile ha
fatto una sfilata che non saprei fare
ragazzi incredibile pazzesca come l'ho
ripresa questa per favore agli anni
trenta
merda merda ok no ma dai lavori presa la
pizza l'ordinata quindi siamo a posto
almeno ho sentite facciamo la facciamo
faccio una roba seria social ora se
allora facciamo famiglie il cubo molto
semplice il gioco più esilarante ma a me
due anni fa l'avevo fatto comunque
bellissimo da copertina complimenti poi
j
marco l'ora penali gianmarco sono molto
contento però non avevo anche fatto flop
no vabbè klopp volta che faccio già
vista incazzando mara ho fatto niente ho
fatto punteggio di merda 22 22.3 beh
allora rispetto al 2019 ha migliorati e
allora questo che avevo fatto un europa
ma volta guarda guarda erogata 58 60
metri come mezzo mondo farr 60 metri nel
2013 dentro la marmotta avevo tipo degli
e ratatouille che mi onora senso sta
cosa comunque ero arrivato a 60 metri
giocando normalmente come car che avevo
fatto spiega temi che quasi arrivato a
30 per grazia di dio
è impossibile o che comunque pazzesco se
ci pensate come cacchio fatto a fare 60
metri quello il mio record totale 61
metri allora ragazzi quanto è vero iddio
adesso continuo finché non mi arriva la
pizza non ne sbatto vado avanti così
tutta la sera piuttosto me ne frega le
mille palle ok ci mette mezz'ora da
adesso arriva alla pizzeria vado avanti
finché non ci deve lo giuro che lo ami
citofono a noi e vado avanti non ne
voglio sapere
td
[Musica]
no
cosa come puoi aiutarmi disinstalla sta
merda
porco un ostacolo cerno st 20 mila
ricoprite buttati nel cesso nora che io
veramente non
51 mentre c'è un ostacolo di ma come
avevo fatto come ho fatto quando nel
2013 come come come l'avevo superato
l'ostacolo porco il demonio morto ieri
come avevo fatto non si può superare un
ostacolo questo gioco di me non puoi
neanche camminare come pretendi che io
superi uno stacco cosa devo far saltare
cosa ma poi sui 50 metri metti un
ostacolo ma se veramente ma dai ragazzi
abbiamo fatto una corsa è idilliaca
[Musica]
no gli ho dato una testata gli ho dato
porco dei bonus e zidane theo basta
150 cm 8 ore per tornare al 50 mente
ancora mi ricordo la vis è incredibile
non so però basse sono sudato sono
sudato mamma mio cioè non avevi detto
prima di chiudere scusate mi sembra che
cigs e vabbè sì certo no no vabbè ma mi
sembra una cosa un attimo skillato
madonna mia questo quadro è bello se non
è il viaggio bezos c'è proprio
avrà gnocca che il cade dal cielo
pazzesca rara
e quindi alla fine cosa che c'è jump a
perché c'è il salto da fare alla fine
national hero
va bene che vi sia piaciuto che sarà qv
ok ragazzi spero che vi ricordiate tutti
nella magnificenza di questa perla
comunque nonostante a parte la tastiera
che si un po spaccata comunque sia non
ho fatto un brutto punteggio cioè
comunque vi sfido a fare almeno 20 metri
il suo gioco ve l'assicuro impossibile
come sono ragazzi televisione ci
argomento è un mi piace anche per i
social che come la descrizione sono
state fischiate viene sempre ci vediamo
al prossimo video bella ragazza
[Musica]
ma